it's like the king of mob movies return
to mob movies it's a pretty big deal the
Irishman so the Irishman is directed by
Martin Scorsese - straight to Netflix
movie pretty solid grab on Netflix as
parts of solid fishing and this is the
true story suppose a true story based on
a true story which you know the drill by
now if it's based on a true story and
it's a Hollywood movie 50% if it's gonna
be bullsh it's the way it goes but still
based on a true story in that it's
Robert De Niro he plays the man the book
I heard you paint houses is based off of
brilliance movies based off of that book
so what I mean I see him telling the
story of his life and his time and the
mob from there you have a
three-and-a-half-hour Martin Scorsese
mob epic I mean [ __ ] what else did you
want for Christmas that's kind of what I
asked for and I'll say this like Robert
De Niro's great in the movie but
everybody's actually great in the movie
Robert De Niro Joe Pesci Al Pacino
Al Pacino plays Jimmy Hoffa I didn't
know it was going to be very Jimmy Hoffa
centric I didn't watch any of the
trailers for this movie all I knew about
this movie is that it was using D aging
software to make him younger new
technology and all that that kind of
hijacked the whole conversation about
this movie that's all I heard about but
Al Pacino has Jimmy Hoffa's not to be
overlooked here he's great too I just I
guess I really like it when older
celebrities those legacy actors as ones
you're like oh man you crushed it back
in the day you were Hollywood I may be
older now but they still got it that's
how I felt in this movie probably
coupled with the fact that it's Al
Pacino and Robert De Niro in the same
film that concept was the selling point
for a heat for me I was like dude
they're in a movie together and yes it
uses de-aging software it's different
than the Disney de-aging software I have
heard and after seeing it yes it does
appear to be different because Disney
de-aging software's like let's take
Michael Douglas's face and make him
Michael Douglas from basic instinct but
this T aging software seems to keep the
frame of the face and just make it less
wrinkly so they do look younger and it
is really impressive but it's not like
he looks like DeNiro from Goodfellas or
Casino or anything like that active
thinking about it might be because of
how he feels rather than how he looks I
mean but as there's times where he's
moving and you're like
your that's right you're an older guy
body with the younger guy face but it
completely works for the movie because
it's not supposed to be Robert De Niro
the actor he's supposed to be the
younger version of this guy it's really
impressive D aging software for sure
also the runtime that's long yeah it's
three and a half hour Martin Scorsese
epic it might be three hours and 20
minutes I don't want to exaggerate at
that point what's the difference
however thinking about it it's like what
would I take out and I don't know it's
all relevant it all works it's all
important it's just it's the chronicle
of this guy's life and maybe some scenes
could have been shaved down a little bit
I wouldn't take any of the scenes out
maybe they could have been shorter but
they could have been shorter in casino
to casino could have been a two-hour
movie it's not because that's the kind
of epics that Martin Scorsese makes and
it's kind of what's cool about it and
cool about him and I've liked that I'm
not gonna draw the line for him now I
was like look casino was fine making a
movie that's slightly longer than casino
no some scenes could have been shaved to
be shorter but I'm glad they weren't so
kind of like hateful eight on Netflix
the hateful eight extended edition I
believe it's called on Netflix is
essentially four one-hour episodes which
makes it a four hour movie but because
it's broken up into episodes it feels
different so on one hand maybe they
should have done that with the Irishman
however you also have the ability to
watch about an hour of the Irishmen
pause or stop it come back the next day
pick it back up watch an hour of the
Irishmen and break it up among four days
or so you can do that nothing stopping
you you can kind of execute the Irishman
how Netflix naturally executes the
hateful eight extended edition for you
cuz also I can't say it's not engaging
it's completely engaging I turn this on
at midnight and I was like alright I'll
watch the first half now go to bed then
watch the second half tomorrow yeah
you're right I watched it all that night
in my experience when people are talking
about a movies runtime really what
they're talking about is the movies time
management and pacing and admittedly if
I'm being honest this movie does get a
little long-winded at times in certain
scenes so by the end of it I appreciated
all of it because it all works for the
world-building
I wasn't watching this movie to get to
the end of the movie I was watching the
Irishman to live in the world it works
for me and all that world building does
pay off because by the end when the
movie and the character is being very
reflective it makes you very reflective
not in the world you just saw but on
your own life that's a powerful thing
that this movie completely did pull off
I really
appreciated that I love this movie for
that so in the end the Irishman I
thought was a great return to form for
Martin Scorsese his return to mobster
movies like he swore them off 40 years
ago or anything because that feel like
hasn't made him in a while I thought it
was engaging thought-provoking
insightful everyone in the movie did a
great job I thought the characters were
great for me it's not quite as good as
Goodfellas Casino or the department but
I loved it he's a damn good filmmaker
and he made a damn good film now that
the Irishman is worth watching and worth
buying on blu-ray cuz if you don't own
the physical copy you're just renting it
folks I'm just saying all right so the
Irishmen have you seen it what did you
think about it or what's your favorite
Martin Scorsese film whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more